hey guys dr. Berg here I wanted to
touch on the difference between eating
raw vegetables and cooked vegetables
first of all the purpose of eating
vegetables is to get the vitamins and
the minerals that you need from a good
source okay now when something is raw
vs. cooked the difference is raw has
enzymes in that vegetable enzymes are
very very good for you and that helps
break down the food and it gives you
great properties health properties but
the problem is that many people are
missing the normal enzymes that the
pancreas are supposed to release to be
able to digest some of these fibers in
the vegetable for example if I consume
broccoli it will cause serious pain in
my intestinal tract
I can consume cabbage all day long I
could do kale but broccoli for some
reason tears me up so that's not
necessarily an allergy it's a missing
enzyme that creates inflammation and
I'll feel like I have a cramp
for the next hour so it's very
uncomfortable so what that means is that
somehow along the line I had some damage
in my pancreas and I couldn't I couldn't
generate those enzymes so that's one one
thing but there's other things too if
your stomach has low acid and the way
you know your stomach has low acid is
that you have indigestion like you eat
food it gets stuck there or you have
acid reflux or you have GERD or you
might have constipation or bloating
that means the acids are lower and if
the acids are lower it it we can't
create the triggering effect for the
release of enzymes from your pancreas so
that could be the very reason why you're
not releasing the enzymes because when I
was in college grad school I was taking
the mega packs of Rolaids because I had
heartburn that crazy little did I know
that was caused by not enough acid from
all the stress that I was going through
but that's something that you can if you
actually just increase the pH of the
stomach acidify the stomach many times
you can see a great benefit of the full
digestion of even vegetables so that's
something to look at the next thing is
that
you have low good bacteria in your gut
if the bacteria by the way 90% of this
friendly bacteria does most does the
digestion in the small intestine if you
don't have enough of that then you're
going to get a lot of bloating and
excess fermentation and rotting and all
sorts of problems but these microbes are
the things that make enzymes for these
fibers in other words they live on fiber
now if you're not used to consuming kale
or a lot of other vegetables that you
don't normally eat like even broccoli or
cabbage maybe you have just like iceberg
lettuce or spring green and then you
switch over you haven't developed the
enzymes yet and these microbes have to
grow and adapt to your foods over a
slower period of time before you can
digest them so if you change over and
you feel like you're not losing way and
you feel bloated all that means is
you've got to cut it back you're not
ready to consume that many vegetables
because that's too much fiber for these
microbes to deal with now what I do is I
have you go back to those vegetables
that you were consuming before and
gradually introduce it until you can
achieve seven - you know 10 cups of
vegetables but you have to sometimes
ease into it you can't do it overnight
the other thing you can do is you can
steam the vegetables or cook them that
way you can break them down a little bit
more and it's a lot easier on the system
to digest and you still get the same
minerals you might not have all the
vitamins but you still get the good
minerals that you need from these
vegetables so that's one way and then
also fermented vegetables like
sauerkraut kimchi all these ferment
pickles
those are really easy to digest because
the lactic acid from the bacteria in
that they make that from has already
broke it down for you so you can consume
with some of that and that will really
help your system but again some people
can't tolerate too much so what I like
to do go for some raw but try not to go
too much to the point where you feel
bloated so you have to adjust that
adjust the amount of raw vegetables
until you have no bloating okay and no
side effects
but again we have to slowly go into this
make sure you maybe increase your
acidity in your stomach maybe use a
probiotic to start building up or just
start off slowly introducing over time
so you can develop your own microbes and
your body can adapt to that situation
okay so that's the only point I want to
make between these two so go ahead and
comment below and I'll see in the next
video